the Indo-European language family
includes languages as diverse as English
Spanish Greek Russian Persian and Hindi
which have been changing and diverging
from each other for thousands of years
and are now radically different from
their common ancestor language
proto-indo-european it's often said that
the Indo-European languages that retain
the most similarities to
proto-indo-european are the Baltic
languages that doesn't mean that they're
the same as proto-indo-european they're
most certainly quite different but they
are the most conservative of the living
Indo-European languages and retain some
features lost in other ones there are
only two Baltic languages that are
living languages today Lithuanian and
Latvian though the latgalian dialect of
Latvian is sometimes considered a
distinct language and so is the Samo
Gideon dialect of Lithuanian people
don't talk about these languages very
much and that might be because they're
not spoken by a huge number of people
Lithuanian is the native language of
around 2.38 million people in Lithuania
that's 85 percent of the population and
the majority of the others speak it as a
second language and a couple hundred
thousand people speak it outside of
Lithuania Latvian is the native language
of around 1.17 million people in Latvia
that's 62.1 percent of the population
most of the others are native speakers
of Russian especially in the latgale
region where there's a large ethnic
Russian population if we exclude that
region Latvian is the native language of
the vast majority of people around a
hundred thousand people speak it outside
of Latvia as well Latvian and Lithuanian
have a lot of vocabulary and features in
common but are still quite different and
not mutually intelligible for the most
part Lithuanian is the more conservative
of the two it's worth noting that while
Estonia is a Baltic country the Estonian
language is not Baltic it's a finnic
language and comes from completely
different Origins we'll talk about the
origin of the Baltic languages in a
moment but first let's talk about a
software tool with numerous benefits for
all of you World Travelers and language
enthusiasts I'm talking about the
sponsor of this video Atlas VPN right
now they have an amazing sale price of
just a dollar ninety nine a month which
you should definitely take advantage of
I use Atlas VPN to view content online
that's exclusive to certain countries
when I want to watch shows or movies in
a different language I use Atlas VPN to
make streaming services think I'm in a
country where that language is spoken
giving me access to more local content
you can also use Atlas VPN to keep your
Google searches and downloads private
like if you're traveling in a country
where an invasive government might be
monitoring your online activity or if
you're worried about big Tech using your
data it also stops elicit ads malware
and trackers and notifies you of
attempts to use your data also a VPN can
help you get the best online prices like
the time I saved hundreds of dollars on
a stock music subscription by using the
American version of the site rather than
my local version I prefer not to be
ripped off thank you very much so Atlas
VPN is a very useful tool all over the
world and it's the best deal all over
the world at only 1.99 per month for a
three-year subscription on unlimited
devices with a 30 day money back
guarantee but time is run running out so
be sure to lock in that low price by
clicking the link in the description
down below
it's theorized that the Baltic languages
share a common ancient origin with the
Slavic languages both tracing back to
protobalto Slavic as far back as 3500
years ago then protobaltic split into
Western Baltic which consisted of old
Prussian and other extinct languages and
Eastern Baltic which consists of
Lithuanian and Latvian it's thought that
the Baltic languages are conservative
because of the isolation of the Baltic
peoples in northern Europe during the
early migrations further south it's
thought that Latvian has changed more
because of contact between the Eastern
Baltic tribes and finnic people called
the livonians the Eastern vaults further
south in Lithuania though bordered the
Western bolts whose languages were even
more conservative so Lithuanian was less
prone to change from non-baltic
influence but we have little direct
evidence of how the Baltic language is
developed because they weren't written
until Prussia to the southwest of
Lithuania and Latvia were conquered in
the northern Crusades and converted to
Christianity in the 13th century coming
under German influence and colonized
position the oldest existing piece of
writing in a Baltic language dates to
the 14th century and is written in Old
Prussian which was spoken in Prussia it
was also in Prussia that the Lithuanian
language was first written in the 15th
century in the northeastern area where
Lithuanian was spoken known as Lithuania
minor the oldest Latvian writing dates
to the 16th century all three languages
were influenced by German in orthography
and vocabulary and in the case of old
Prussian the language died out by the
18th century due to the germanization
and assimilation of its speakers from
the 16th to 18th centuries Lithuania and
parts of Prussia were part of the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth Latvia then
called Livonia was part of the
Commonwealth at first but was later
conquered by Sweden during the time of
the Commonwealth polish became the
language of the upper class and was used
widely in urban areas as a result polish
loanwords entered Latvian and especially
Lithuanian here are some example words
of Polish origin that are still used in
Lithuanian
meaning pocket from polishing
meaning Tower from polish bashta pashtas
meaning mail or post from polish potsta
which traces back to Italian
meaning cabbage from polish kapusta and
so on in 1721 Swedish Livonia which is
today Latvia was conquered by the
Russian Empire and then after the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth was partitioned
in the 1790s much of the territory
inhabited by Baltic peoples came under
the control of the Russian Empire which
attempted to rucify the population for
instance from 1865 to 1904 they banned
all Lithuanian print media using the
Latin script insisting on Cyrillic
instead but lithuanians continued to use
the Latin script in secret smuggling in
books that were printed across the
border in Lithuania minor part of the
German Empire at the time in Latvia 2
the Russian language was promoted over
Latvian and in the latigale region where
ethnic Russians live publishing and
distributing books in Latvian was
outlawed the Baltic peoples were defiant
towards russification with increasing
nationalism and efforts to create new
standardized forms of the Lithuanian and
Latvian languages removing German polish
and Russian influences though not
entirely the Lithuanian and Latvian
languages were strengthened in all areas
of life after the Baltic countries
became independent following the first
world war but in the 1940s they were
once again occupied and forcibly
incorporated into the Soviet Union once
again a policy of rucification was
imposed on the Baltic countries which
this time included many settlers being
imported from Russia Today over a third
of the population in Latvia speaks
Russian as their native language in
Lithuania it's around 6.5 percent and
polish is just slightly higher but once
again the Baltic peoples were defiant
and maintained their languages and
cultures since 1991 they've been
independent again in Lithuanian and
Latvian are the official Lang languages
of their respective countries features
one similarity between Lithuanian and
Latvian is obviously the resilience of
their speakers and their determination
to preserve their languages but the
languages themselves share many
similarities as well both languages are
quite conservative retaining some
features lost in most Indo-European
languages they're highly inflected
meaning that words have many different
forms that indicate grammatical
information about the word both
languages have seven cases as opposed to
eight and proto-indo-european or perhaps
nine nominative genitive dative
accusative instrumental locative and
vocative the exact case endings are
different from each other but they use
the same seven cases here's an example
word meaning wolf in either language
first in Latvian in the nominative vilks
accusative vilco genitive
bilkum instrumental locative bilka and
vocative Bilk and then there are the
plural forms for each case and the
Lithuanian vilkus vilga
and then there are the plural forms
the case endings are not always the same
as those ones though Latvian has six
different declension patterns in other
words six different sets of case endings
three masculine and three feminine while
Lithuanian has five declension patterns
so you have to remember a whole lot of
noun forms
verbs in both languages also consist of
a stem plus inflectional suffixes
they're conjugated for person and number
but the third person singular and third
person plural forms are the same these
sentences mean the baby cries in Latvian
and in Lithuanian
these sentences mean the babies cry in
Latvian
and a Lithuanian
you can see that while the subject
changes the verb form doesn't you
probably also notice that the words are
totally different some Latvian a
Lithuanian vocabulary is similar but a
lot is not but actually a Lithuanian
speaker would likely understand this
Latvian sentence because the words have
cognates in Lithuanian these words would
mean something slightly different like
the little one Weeps
both languages are generally pro-drop in
first and second person meaning that a
subject pronoun isn't necessary because
the verb suffix tells us the subject for
example these sentences mean I went and
you went in Latvian yes
but they're not pro drop in the third
person because of ambiguity between
third person singular and third person
plural these sentences mean he went and
they went in Latvian Vince Gaia vinigaya
and a Lithuanian yes
neither Lithuanian nor Latvian has
definite or indefinite articles but in
both languages there are definite and
indefinite forms of adjectives that tell
us the definiteness of the noun they
modify for example these words mean
either a stone or the stone in Latvian
uhmins and in Lithuanian
but let's add an adjective meaning blue
a blue stone Zales ockmans the blue
stone the lies augments
is
important to note though that the
definite adjectives aren't the normal
Lithuanian and are optional and are most
commonly used for proper nouns and
certain notable objects note that these
definite forms here are for the
nominative case in the singular but the
indefinite and definite forms differ
depending on case and number so there
are many different forms of each
adjective definiteness and adjectives
traces back to protobalto Slavic and
still occurs in Slavic languages as well
both languages have quite variable word
order because all the inflections help
us know the function of the words in the
sentence so we rely Less on word order
for that information for example these
sentences meaning the man caught a fish
in Latvian video
which is SVO and in Lithuanian
which is also SVO but it could also be
sov beta
and actually six different word orders
are possible
both languages have lost the distinction
between who and what both are Cas in
both languages these sentences both mean
who is that and what is that in Latvian
who or what that is is the third person
singular form of meaning to be and in
Lithuanian who or what that it could
also be
like the Latvian sentence but the verb
to be is optional in the present tense
both languages have pitch accent there
are tonal distinctions in heavy
syllables in other words stressed long
vowels diphthongs and mixed diphthongs
meaning a simple vowel followed by a
nasal sound or an L or R sound but it's
a little different in either language in
Lithuanian there's a two-tone
distinction a falling tone marked with
an acute accent or a rising tone marked
with a tilde tone distinctions can
indicate a difference in meaning for
example
meaning chisel and Cultus meaning guilty
in Latvian there's a three-tone
distinction level written with a tilde
falling written with a grav accent or
broken written with a circumflex for
example the meaning that one in the
feminine meaning like that
meaning that once in the masculine
genitive
another difference in their phonology is
that in Latvian stress is always on the
first syllable whereas in Lithuanian the
accent is variable for example the word
for grass and Latvian is zal while in
Lithuanian it's Julie
the first syllable stress of Latvian is
thought to be from the influence of the
finnic language spoken by the livonians
while Latvian has some palatal
consonants in Lithuanian consonants
before front vowels or any palatalized
consonants are always palatalized like
in Belarusian and Russian we can see
that in the words for grass we saw a
moment ago zal in Latvian and in
Lithuanian notice that the L Sound is
palatalized in the Lithuanian word
while Latvian and Lithuanian have a lot
of cognate vocabulary they also have a
lot of different vocabulary and of
course there are lots of false Friends
words that look and sound similar but
have different meanings a couple of
examples Mounds merliness the Latvian
word means black the Lithuanian word
means blue
the Latvian word means art and the
Lithuanian word means science
and even though there are a lot of
cognates between the two languages that
doesn't mean they're always identical or
obvious it often requires some
deciphering for example I drank in
Latvian
and in Lithuanian
it may not be immediately obvious that
the verbs here are cognates Latvian and
Lithuanian but when attempting to read
either of the two languages the good
news is that the words are spelled how
they sound for the most part this is
because Lithuanian and Latvian were
standardized rather late including their
orthography but reading Lithuanian words
requires a bit more knowledge of the
languages phonology in this case that
consonants are palatalized before front
vowels but once you know those rules you
can pronounce the words based on how
they're written as you can see the
Baltic languages are fascinating
languages with a rich set of features
but those features probably make
learning one of them very intimidating
especially for people whose native
language doesn't have so many inflected
forms you'll often hear people claim
that the Baltic languages especially
Lithuanian are basically the same
language as proto-indo-european but
these claims are very much exaggerated
while they are very conservative and
preserve many old features they've also
changed in many ways and other branches
of Indo-European preserve some features
that the Baltic languages don't that's
not a good thing or a bad thing it's
just how it is the question of the day
if you're a speaker of Latvian or
Lithuanian how well do you understand
the other language and to other people
do you notice any features of your own
language that are similar to the Baltic
languages
I'd like to give a shout out to all of
the langfocus patreon supporters who
make it possible to bring you
educational content like this I'd
especially like to thank the patrons
whose names appear on the screen because
they are the top tier patreon supporters
so let's give them a round of applause
as I mentioned in the video the Baltic
languages are thought to trace back to
the protobalto Slavic language before
Baltic and Slavic branched off from each
other check out my video on the Slavic
languages it's six or seven years old
and pretty embarrassing but you might
still learn a thing or two